five four three two
fantastic so folks we have a special
show for you here today we have the
great daniel de martino booth here with
us to my right and to my left we have
leon cooperman whom we talked about on a
podcast
i want to say i don't know two months
ago tyler we talked about leon cooperman
an article came out the moral
calculations of a billionaire like what
did i do wrong as a billionaire leon
being a billionaire himself uh maybe
you've given all of it away i don't know
if you've given all of it in the in the
process of giving it all the way not
easy not easy yeah i bet 25 years at
goldman partnered there 25 years with
omega hedge fund manager you started it
there and then now you're trying to give
away all your money that's your story
there's no shortage of worthwhile
organizations so i'll succeed
um
you know i've been very lucky and uh you
know people ask me what do i attribute
my success to you know i started out in
the south bronx i'm the first generation
of my family born in america my father
came to america from poland at the age
of 13 as a plumber's apprentice no
formal education
um and i went to public school in the
south bronx high school in the south
bronx and then i followed the advice of
harlots greeley i went west and i went
to college in the west bronx part of the
city university of new york
and i've been very lucky
and people ask me what do i treat my
success to i say luck hard work i did
work very hard i still work very hard
and intuition so the hard work and luck
is easy to understand intuition requires
more explanation so i give them two
examples of intuition
which is important
back in the 60s if you finish your major
and minor in college in three years
you're allowed to count your first year
of medical or dental school towards your
fourth year of college and get a
separate degree
and in the summer of 1963 i took
physical chemistry at the university of
pennsylvania
to finish off my major my major was
chemistry
and
then i enrolled in the university of
pennsylvania dental school in august of
1963
and after eight days this is intuition
now
i start to wonder if i was going down a
path i was fully committed so
it was a very traumatic time because you
know i paid room and board for a year i
paid tuition for a year my father may
rest in peace was pissed as hell at me
when i told him i wasn't sure i wanted
to go to dental school
the only guy that appreciated the
significance of the decision was glenn t
nygren who's deceased he was a dean of
hunter had to approve my matriculating
back into undergraduate school
and he said very heroic decision of
course you can come back
and i had all electives available and i
took 10 courses in my senior year in
economics got 10 a's i never looked back
so that's intuition you know because
it's a very difficult thing you know to
basically walk away from room and board
and tuition and i drove my initials lc
into 1200 worth of equipment because i
tell you things have a way of
disappearing in the laboratory
and then a second example of intuition
uh back in the 1960s
wall street was at a very high point and
uh
basically i had 16 job offers
very different environment today and 16
job offers yeah well i was an attractive
package at a six month old kid so i was
a serious guy i knew what i wanted to do
i was beta gamma sigma i was wall street
journal student achievement award and i
was straight a's in finance
and uh goldman was the fourth best offer
i had and financially who was the best
one uh i don't remember i'm not sure
lazard or somebody like that maybe
america is that 1966 i was interviewing
got it and so um well i'm very anal and
i'm very reliable if i say i'm going to
be in your studio at nine o'clock i was
here at nine o'clock i was actually a
little earlier
and
i got a call from bob danforth who is
the gentleman that extended the offer to
me and said lee we're disappointed we
haven't heard from you
and what can we say i said bob let me be
honest with you i was very knowledgeable
the compound interest tables that union
carbide had set around at the time
and it offers for 12 500 i said do you
think i can make 25 000 in five years
which is 15 compounded double
and he said if you work hard and keep
your nose clean i think you could do it
because i'll tell you why i liked
everybody i met at goldman even though
you're my fourth best offer financially
uh come with goldman
and that turned out to be a great
decision because one of the few firms
that didn't change their name i got
elected to the partnership in 1976
ten years later yeah yeah nine nine
years later and basically
when i got elected to partnership the
firm had a record year they earned 40
million dollars in 1976.
and when i retired 14 years later they
earned 1.8 billion i was there for the
whole run
and you lived through the death of
equities yeah yeah that was uh in 1982 i
think cover the business week yeah
yeah 19 actually 72 maybe
the other cover that was dumb of
business week was the one where they my
hero in life was henry singleton the
founder of teledyne and the guy was
absolutely brilliant the smash guy ever
dealt with and uh in august of 1982
basically businessweek had him on the
cover picked pictured as icarus the
mythical greek god that flew too close
to saw those wax wings melted and
crashed earth i wrote him a seven page
letter saying how foolish they were this
guy was really a genius
and warren buffett got a hold of it and
had
sent me a letter and i call this my one
of my big mistakes in life
because he sent me a letter which i
framed in 1982.
i framed it but i didn't buy a stock if
i framed his letter i must have thought
very well of him right
way before he was
viewed as the the genius which he is
and he sent me that dearly i always
enjoy the quality of your writing the
quality of your thinking your letter to
businessweek retell that was 100 the
mark best regards warren
i framed that letter it's hanging on my
office wall to this day but i never
bought a stock which is a big mistake a
big miss
never bought this dog never bought a big
mess and but if you thought so well of
them to hang a letter from them and they
were [ __ ] about some of the stuff yeah
that was a big one
that means you walk on walk you don't
walk on water you're not which is good
there's something in this business if
you don't make mistakes you're either a
liar or you don't make decisions
absolutely i got a question for you so
you said luck hard work intuition if you
were to you seem like you're a data guy
for sure you're a data guy what would
you say percentage-wise cause a lot of
people say it's 80 luck some people say
it's 80 hard work what would you say
with your experience
uh i don't know 60 40 to be different 60
luck
uh hard work 60s hard work how do you
work the luckier you get okay so fine
that's the truth and then where you put
intuition
uh very important in my case it was
paramount importance you know you got to
go with your gut and i tell these young
people today i do a lot of talking at
colleges you know basically
you've got to basically have good
intuition you have to have good judgment
you can't teach that though
no but uh listen
all throughout life we all have setbacks
and what makes you successful is how you
handle those setbacks i've had my
setbacks and i came roaring back
what's your biggest one
well i hired a guy at a goldman who
turned out to be a crook and
violated the foreign corrupt practices
act uh and implicated the implicated the
firm
we knew nothing about it uh the
government is a bunch of criminals
because they try to you know they don't
want to know the truth they just want to
basically embarrass you
and i had to fight through that and i
won
in the end but it was very very
difficult situated very costly i had a
billion dollars of capital left the firm
but you know we came
back that's the comeback so question in
regards to capitalism you've been around
for a while and you've seen how media
presents the wealthy
uh socialists are not a new thing
they've been around for a while they've
been doing this for a while i saw
one-year quotes in this article
uh with what do you call it with uh
wahpo that you did and the other
gentleman that did the universe which i
thought was pretty fair you said one
quote here
you said capitalism has flaws but
socialism has no benefits well i quote
winston churchill he said the main vice
of capitalism and even distribution of
prosperity the main vice of socialism is
the equal distribution of misery one of
my other heroes in life is ken langone
who's one of the finest youtubers i've
ever really is a fabulous guy if you
haven't read his book you got to read it
i love it i read it i read it you know
he and i have a lot in common his father
was a plumber in long island my dad was
a plumber in the bronx
and i i think the world of ken and ken
says he'd like to take his private plane
and fly these young kids that think
socialism is superior to capitalism to
venezuela and cuba and see what it's all
about i went to cuba about six or seven
years ago on a mission and you know it
takes three hours to get from the out
from the suburbs to downtown
uh to get to their work because they
have no organized transportation system
their cell phones of course i think
three dollars and 85 cents a minute this
is five years ago they all drive around
1955 chevrolet three dollars and 45
cents a minute 3.85 a minute
five years ago five years ago
and they can't afford it and they're the
only capitalists in the country are the
hookers
wow
i live i lived in venezuela i mean i was
i was witness to the craziness before
chavez came on
and know there's something to be said
about
you know how desperate people get when
there's an inequality divide in the
united states like there is but that's
not the solution
not the solution at all you know what
we'll change though what i'm trying to
find out with you is so 25 years goldman
25 years omega 1966 is when you took the
job offer with 12 500 with 15 rate
growth over five years you'll make
twenty five thousand dollars and i'm
assuming you made it i made 180 000 in
the fifth year right so ninth year they
have that big you know you become a
partner 40 million dollars and then 1.8
billion dollars you've been through the
whole ride as you went through and then
start your own company the relationship
between the capitalist and media
and the youth there's always been a
relationship right more poor people than
rich people and the politicians like to
play that up i had this battle with
elizabeth warren who i consider a
politician
in the worst sense of the word so i gave
a speech at a
conference about three or four years ago
at a time when she was running strongly
in the polls and the moderator asked me
what do i think the market would do if
elizabeth warren won and i said we'll go
down 20 percent
next day not knowing anything about me
she tweets leon i'm only looking for two
percent there's the wealth tax which is
complete [ __ ] uh give others a shot
the american dream so i think long and
hard and i decided to tell you michelle
obama made a comment when they go low we
go high and i sent her a very very good
five-page letter which i'd recommend if
you don't have you get it
in fact it was so good
that larry summers
who's a liberal economist and a very
bright man calls me up and says you know
if you submit that paper in a class i
gave at harvard i'd give you an a plus
not an a plus
what does she write next day
no doesn't address anything i wrote in
the letter which was very respectful
very balanced i thought we all got to
work together to fix the problem she
comes back and says inside trader where
i had this
problem with the government i won the
case and owned stock and navient which
was irrelevant to the situation she
doesn't like student loan companies
and
made no attempt to address the substance
of my letter and so i look as a
politician the worst sense of the word
then a year later she invites me to fear
me before one of the committees in
washington i turn it down and she says
on tv that i was afraid to meet with her
i wrote another letter i said i'm not
afraid to meet with you but i sent you a
very serious letter where basically
somebody commented was an a plus paper
and a liberal economist and you dissed
it and never responded to it i'll meet
you in any program on tv uh to debate
you what's how do you get to be a
billionaire in the economy you know
basically you get to be a billionaire
you develop a product or service that
the world needs and you get rewarded for
it and most billionaires i know give the
money back to society
you know and
i love telling the story i'm very
friendly with bernie marcus who lives in
my community in florida and you know
bernie i think was terminated by sandy
siegeloff on a wednesday night he calls
up ken langone in tears saying i got
three kids a big mortgage i have no
income and then go who's a
tough guy yes he says what the hell are
you moaning about i'll raise your money
you open your superstore so he gets 40
families to put up 50 000 each raises 2
million dollars the market cap of home
depot today is over 300 billion dollars
ken and bernie have given away billions
of dollars to
charity both i think have taken the
giving pledge with buffett uh there are
3 000 employees at home depot that are
worth over a million dollars as a result
of stockholm it's amazing
if you could explain to me what's wrong
with that picture you know i i believe
in the progress you're going fast folks
i don't know if you caught that over 3
000 employees who have a net worth of a
million dollars plus
because of a capitalist got together and
did this please continue yeah and so you
know you broke my train of thought but
basically no he said what are you crying
for here's the money
there's 3 000 millionaires yeah yeah
but basically i'm saying if you tell me
what's wrong with that picture the world
is better off because of bill gates jeff
bezos and larry ellison and bernie
marcus they're amazing employers yeah
you know what's crazy in that book i
love capitalism i recommend it to a lot
of people there's a story he tells i
think i want to say ken's dad died at 62
years old maybe 63.
and he says his dad died
from a basic we could have saved him he
says i've been on blood thinners i don't
know how long he's been on blood
thinners he says i've been on blood
thinner since 50s or since i was 60. he
says if capitalist capital because of
capitalism we now have blood thinners
where my dad would have lived an
additional 20 years because i think ken
is in his 80s right now late 70s early
30s 85 85 yeah so think about a
capitalist creates a business he's in
great shape though because he goes to
gym every day he goes to church every
day
he's he's the largest guy he's a very
unique guy he's a very special yeah i i
i i was inspired by him but the part i
want you to unpack and educate us i know
the story about elizabeth warren this is
me i'm 43. i lived in iran 10 years i
saw what happened when they divided iran
and then there was a fall i went to
germany i've been here i've seen from
1990 to today that's the politics i know
i came here november 20th 1990
and i grew up watching the life of the
rich and famous it wasn't as it was
aspirational to be
a real estate mogul to be wealthy to be
somebody today to me it's different
because they're being bashed is that
just a new thing or has it always been
like this or is it worse today than ever
it's getting worse because income
disparity has been greater exactly and
the income disparity to some degree
results from government policy you know
in the 2008 economic downturn uh
bernanke ahead of the fed at the time
said we got to get the economy turned
around what's the best way to get the
common turnaround is to create wealth
how do you create wealth you get the
stock market up trouble is 80 of stocks
are owned by 20 of the people
okay and then we spent the next 15 20
years trying to get the money back from
the wealthy people by having a negative
return on savings which are disincentive
we've had screwed up policies i listen
to these people we don't need a wealth
tax raise the marginal income tax get
rid of uh 1031 which enables these real
estate guys to
roll forward and definitely get capital
gains taxation eliminate carried
interest uh special taxation for hedge
funds and private equity firms that
would be here get rid of the get rid of
the loopholes you know i i have no
problem paying more in taxes uh but what
you know what i
love quoting and tom sowell the black
conservative economist incredible he
says in this era of social justice what
is your fair share of what someone else
has worked for now you speak to bernie
sanders who's a communist he's not a
socialist he's a communist he says a
marginal tax rate 90 percent you speak
to elizabeth warren she says 70 you
speak to paul krugman new york times 64
you know i'm only work six months for
the government six months for myself i
have no problem with progressive income
tax structure i think the biggest
question we have to confront as a nation
today is what should the maximum tax
rate be on wealthy people because that
will define the revenue yield to the
government the government's got to size
themselves to that revenue yield and i'm
willing to work six months for the
government six months myself and that
sounds about right and fair beyond that
i think it becomes confiscatory
i want to give away i work for my money
i want to give it away i don't want the
government giving it away
so so you know how sometimes a
progressive will say
uh well you know that's all good and
dandy you don't want to go to 64 or 70
or 90 and you're calling bernie a
communist how about the fact that for 40
years the top line taxes you know was uh
income taxes was 90
and how did america make it and middle
america was doing better you'll hear a
progressive saying that what's your
rebuttal to that well back then you had
enormous deductions
which have now been eliminated so what
does that mean tell us what that looks
like well you know you have a lot of
write-offs you can go with oil and gas
ventures and real estate ventures and
other forms of
deducting expenses against your income
so your effective tax rate was not
nearly the number that they talked about
i i think it gets to be a question of
equity you know you work 12 months a
year
what is the government's share of that
what should it be and i think if you
work six months with yourself for six
months the government sounds about right
to me
you know and uh look the end of the day
if you think about it
the wealthy people there's only four
things you can do with money i can i
observed this many many years ago the
first thing you could do with money is
you could spend it on yourself you buy
homes you buy cars you buy art you buy
planes i'm married 57 years the same
woman she was an educator for 35 years
very purposeful and basically she and i
have the same view that material
possessions brings with it aggravation
so we're kind of less is more i drive a
hyundai i don't drive a bentley or a
tesla or a rolls royce
i give away a hundred bentleys a year
charitably um
so i i couldn't spend my money so it's
first thing you do with money spend it
on yourself i'm not an art collector i
miss that game like i miss warren
buffett i miss the art game he said
i'm not into professional sports i'm not
i don't buy teams
second thing you do it might give you
children but my opinion if you have a
lot of money which i developed a lot of
money over the many years giving all
your money your kids a mistake because
you deprive them of self-achievement i
have two terrific kids you know very
different one has a phd in environmental
sciences but he worked for his phd the
other one has an mba from wharton
graduate stand for phi beta capital
respect and he uh he worked very hard
and i never gave my kids money until
they were older
um and they didn't what age what age
wasn't uh in the 40s oh you didn't give
them the money till you so they had to
make their own money till 40. yeah well
you don't want to deprive them of
self-achievement how's your relationship
with them excellent they come home
the only better relationship to have is
with their kids yeah people ask me all
the time what's the greatest gift you
can give to your children financial
independence yeah yeah my kids my kids
still come home
the grandkids is the ones you have a
problem with no no i said uh no i have
no problem i have a terrific family
i i said i i a friend of mine who just
recently passed away said if he knew how
much enjoyment he'd have from his
grandkids he never would have kids who
just had grandkids
but
no i have three grandkids
24 year old 21 year old and a 13 year
old and they're terrific kids
and i'm very close with them and uh
so i'd say the first thing you're doing
money spending yourself i'm not a big
spender and that i'm not cheap but
there's nothing i want you know anything
i want i can get i can afford it but
there's nothing i want second thing you
do with money give it to your children
and explain that that's a mistake if you
have a lot of money third thing you do
with your money is give it to government
but only a schmuck gives the government
money you don't have to give them you
pay your taxes as a taxpayer but you
don't volunteer to pay more the fourth
thing you do with money is recycle back
in society and to try to make the world
a better place and that's what i've
elected to do with my vast bulk of my
money and i get a great deal of
enjoyment next to seeing my kids and my
grandkids grow old with health and
purpose i'd say helping others less
fortunate is a highlight of my life what
what are your favorite causes well it's
not the biggest number but
the one that i like the most because
it's impactful is uh cooperman coward
scholars
so many years ago i made a decision to
put 25 million dollars into a fund to
send 500 kids to college the criteria
was and this is you had to live in essex
county new jersey or have a home
you had to be academically qualified i'm
big on equal opportunity but not equal
outcomes certain kids shouldn't go to
college you're better off being
tradesmen
third thing is you have to have a
financial need i met by government and
fourth you have to show the initiative
and enroll in a free three-week
pre-college program designed by franklin
and marshall which explains these kids
what to expect in college
so when i gave them the 25 million i
said look i know the statistics they're
not encouraging 35 of newark high school
kids went to college only five percent
graduated i said i busted my butt for
this money i'm not going to throw down a
rat hole you got to show me uh
improvement
well our first cohort graduated and
thanks to twinkle morgan
and norm atkins who run the program for
me we had a 73 graduation rate which is
competitive nationwide so i gave him a
second 25 million so i gave him 50
million to send a thousand kids to
college you're really changing lives the
average lifetime earnings of a college
graduate is about a million dollars plus
more than a non-college graduate plus
you give them skills to be more
competitive in the world so i've done
that
more recently i say this with a laugh
they swapped a saint for a jew but i
gave a hundred plus million dollars to
saint barnabas medical center which is
now called cooperman barnabas i gave a
large gift to boca regional hospital
uh i gave a very large gift from new
jersey performing arts center it's a
whole bunch of things there's no
shortage of people
and uh that are looking for money very
honorable what you've done with with all
that giving i think a lot of times uh
uh uh people forget like when you make
money what what are you gonna do with
that money when you die i mean crowds
don't have pockets yeah it's it's the
money is eventually gonna go back into
the market it's eventually to go into a
charity it's going to go to a family
it's going to go somewhere and even when
nowadays with the estate taxes the
government's still going to end up
getting some of the money the question
becomes
who does better with money the the free
market enterprise or the government and
if it's legal and i know that answer we
know the answer to the question but you
and i also know that we got to give a
little bit to the government to get
military to get some of the work that
they do if if you had you know the tax
code very well if you had a structure
for tax code that would benefit and
change the gap middle income upper class
the wealthy how would you change the tax
code
well i think i i i believe in the
progressive income next structure i
think we just got to get rid of more of
the loopholes as i said you know 1031
enables all these real estate
entrepreneurs to roll forward and
definitely capital gains get rid of that
let them pay their taxes in my industry
there's this carried interest thing it's
really ordinary income get rid of that
and you know schumer
talks about taxing the wealthy people
he's a new yorker my guess is he's
been responsible for that legislation
not happening exactly right a lot of
real estate people uh live in new york
and a lot of the private equity people
operate in new york we gotta operate
with more enlightened interest rather
than enlightened self-interest
i want to get your thoughts both of your
thoughts on a couple stories that's
coming out here so carl icahn this is a
cnbc story that came out this week carl
icahn says there very well could be a
recession or even
uh
worse uh a
famed investor carl icon said tuesday on
economic downturn could be the on the
horizon and he is loaded on protection
against the steep sell-off in the market
i think
there very well could be a recession or
even worse icon set to cnbc's closing
bell uh to scott webner i have kept
everything hedged for the last few years
we have a strong catch on against the
long positions and we try to be
activists
to get that edge i'm negative as you can
hear short term i don't even predict the
founder and chairman of carl icahn etc
etc do you agree with carl icahn's
position let me just say this he's a
brilliant trader but in 1980 which is
what almost 41 years ago 42 years ago he
closed out his hedge fund returned the
money because he said he didn't like the
outlook and we were on a 10-15 year role
in the economy
he's a brilliant trader you know very
smart guy but he has a bearish bent to
him i don't disagree with him presently
i think we've had the most irresponsible
combination of fiscal monetary policies
in our history
you know i would just point out that if
you had 100 economists in your studio
rather than
a very attractive young lady and
a broken down stock jockey like me
basically and had a hundred economists
in here and asked them what is the
potential real growth of the u.s economy
the response would be probably centered
around two percent real because the real
growth is a function of productivity
growth which is about one and a half
percent per annum and labor force growth
was about half of one percent per annum
most of the last couple years we were
growing at two three four times
potential yet the fed was keeping
interest rates at zero and they pushed
everybody out on the risk curve taking
respect with their bets
six or eight months ago
it wasn't a scott wapner show was on the
squawk box same network i said that if
if
powell was right on inflation i would
tip my hat to him it's not transitory no
and you know the fed had a very very
serious miss on inflation it's going to
take them a few years to get
inflation down to where they want it 64
of a typical business cost is labor and
labor is not coming down and then the
other one on the fiscal side you know
this nation was founded in the 1776
we had very limited national debt in
2017 our debt grew to 20 trillion
dollars from 2017 to 2021 in four years
it's gone from 20 train to 30 trillion
it's a growth rate far in excess of
growth rate economy i think there's a
price to be paid for that and you know
we could very well have a crisis uh
icon could be right but then again like
i said he's a very astute trader a very
smart guy a very generous guy too
um smart guy i mean yeah you don't get
to be worth
you don't get to be worth 18 or 19
billion dollars and yeah exactly but i i
think he's got a point about stagflation
and i think that you're right that the
fiscal policy was 43.2 percent of gdp
inside of two years it was bigger than
the new deal
and we we have nothing productive to
show for it we nothing i mean we've
taught people to not work effectively
which is definitely not the american way
and
at the same time as you said the federal
reserve basically monetized every penny
of it they acted as co-conspirators now
we've got runaway speculation in housing
huge huge uh price inflation and food
and energy and this this was before
ukraine
yeah i think ukraine has been kind of a
smoke screen for him it's a red herring
this was uh it's a serious issue
um you know very hard to make
predictions
about the future but i would say that
um
putin to me is like a uh wounded animal
and a wounded animal that's cornered is
very dangerous what makes him dangerous
is the nuclear capability
you know adolf hitler when he saw he was
losing committed suicide the question is
whether putin has got that capacity
or whether he's going to try to use a
nuclear option and take the rest of the
world with him
and i don't know i don't know the answer
you know i hope not
but that's a very dangerous situation
how much pride do you think putin's got
is he a guy that's driven by a lot of
pride and his publicity like how people
view him and he has to always show
strength i think he can give a damn less
you know that's a good thing though
that's actually good if he doesn't give
a [ __ ] because if he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he won't do what hitler did
if he does care about what history and
people think he's gonna have to do
something because he's
people are selling him right now
somebody who's weak
yeah well uh what my concern is if he
didn't have nuclear capability he's
being exposed here for being a paper
tiger
basically he can't even deal with the
ukraine
exactly
nato yeah well that's a good cause
that's a real concern because if he
resorts to a nuclear
solution very very negative the other
thing i'd watch very carefully is china
now i'm assuming china is a very
mercantilist nation and they see the
market in europe and the market in the
united states is much bigger than the
market in russia so i think they'll stay
out of this
and i think if china stays out of it and
we don't use a nuclear option this too
shall pass yeah i think they've learned
how expensive it would be right now to
invade
basically to try and take taiwan back i
think that xi jinping has learned a big
lesson watching from the outside looking
in what's happening with russia and how
devastating it's been to the economy
yeah absolutely
putin says well with this daily business
briefing putin says unfriendly countries
must buy russian oil and gas in rubles
yeah let's hear it for the italians they
were they were the first to say no
yeah and then by the way meanwhile did
you have an opinion about what saudi
arabia said that they're thinking about
moving away from dollar
to price the oil to wants and since 1972
that price it with u.s dollar now they
want to go that direction
well i think you know if we keep
depreciating the dollar they'll be
looking for they don't have a choice
exactly so you've been you've been very
uh uh
you know critical
almost anybody in in office you've had
some comments about them you i think
that democrats and republicans both are
deficient
uh and let me explain i think the
democratic party has been too solid in
the violence in the cities by black
lives movement you know they they should
be more critical more outspoken
and i think the republican party has put
on with a lot of [ __ ] with trump
you know his behavior was disgraceful
criticizing a hero like john mccain
or uh
you know colin powell in death shows no
judgment whatsoever and so uh very few
people other than like mitt romney and a
couple of others have been critical of
trump trump's economic ideas were
superior but his behavior to bidens but
his behavior was disgraceful and the way
i assess it unemotionally is i know a
lot of very decent hard-working people
that voted generous that voted for trump
and their vote was basically
motivated more because they feared the
progressives more than they fear trump
okay and my view is different we live in
a democracy there are 300 members of the
house 100 u.s senators that can
represent my interest and i felt that i
would rather take a chance with them and
put a would-be dictator into a second
term
where he have no allegiance to anybody
but himself
i do believe his behavior has been
disgraceful and so i voted for biden
and
i voted for biden very reluctantly there
was a vote against trump to be honest
with you and i think the saddest thing
for our country is a country 330 odd
million people we had these two choices
disgraceful so who who are you excited
about for 2024 you live in florida you
got a governor here that some people
like yeah well uh i don't like his
anti-masking stuff
i would say i had lunch the other day
with joe manchin
and i i could support him but i don't
think he could run as a democrat he'll
have to switch parties i agree with you
he sabotaged the uh build back better so
it's hard for me to imagine the
democratic party would put him in the
head of the ticket well he said
the state state of the union address he
sat with the gops and he was in dallas
texas recently for a fundraiser energy
industry
it was all gop fundraising he's got a
lot of common sense and he's got a lot
of fortitude he's been getting calls
every day multiple calls about changing
his vote and he hung tough
and so he i would support him
mike pompeo is going to run chris
christie from new jersey's gonna run you
know there's plenty of people on the
republican side i don't know anybody on
the democratic side that i would vote
for at this point in time newsom
uh i don't know enough about him
that's a star for them
yeah that's a you give that look they
love you he he sent out a fourth
stimulus check to california
billionaires yesterday for gas something
400 per person that makes no sense to me
you're looking to discourage consumption
you don't lower the price no california
hadn't had net out migration for the
first time since 1850 when it became a
state in 2021 they actually had
the what i love to quote he's no longer
governor but
cuomo
andrew cuomo said basically that uh
people are leaving new york because of
the weather
i thought that was a great comment makes
a lot of sense yeah i'll come dead and
leave it the last you know however many
years and decades but trump you think uh
you think trump's running
i had lunch with a very leading democrat
who said two things
very politically connected a very fine
human being i don't feel up i don't feel
it's appropriate to mention his name
and he gave me what i call good news and
bad news
the bad news was trump is going to run
trump's gonna get the nomination and
trump's gonna win i happen to disagree
with him okay the good news was he said
predictions and the presidential outcome
three years in advance have never been
right
it's so funny yeah that's the truth he's
a very leading guy a very major
philanthropist
who's on tv like you quite a lot he did
a great job
but
i don't think the
republican party will give the
nomination to trump when it comes down
to push comes to shove just like a
democratic party denied bernie sanders
they didn't want him to lead the ticket
how important are these midterms
i think it's a lead pipe sense that the
republicans are going to sweep
um
maybe that's what's keeping the market
up but i i think it's a matter of how
they're going to sweep and what the
composition's going to be and whose side
they're on because the
republican party is just as divided as
the democratic party is right now yeah
yeah well
to divide a country do you have any
opinions on lincoln project and what
those guys are doing no no not at all
okay uh david solomon so goldman sachs
when when we were during covet i would
sit down with a lot of investment
bankers talk call them i would have
meetings with them right new york we got
six seven eight meetings with them
and i would say so tell me what your
covet protocols are right now with your
company
and i say well you know we can only do
zoom or we can only do this and we can
only do that and we can go to the office
and we can't travel and behind closed
doors they would say let me tell you the
goldman jets are off they're traveling
they're going and meeting with people
they're sitting down they're meeting
with the entrepreneur they're raising
the money for them they're doing all
that stuff
the reputation of david is they
capitalize during covet
i'm sure you have an opinion about david
solomon who he is and what he's done
what do you think about david solomon's
leadership
outstanding mccumbe is doing extremely
well he's a very gays guy it's a
terrific firm
you know uh
i have nothing but good things to say
about goldman i sat down with a guy that
runs a 10 billion dollar company and we
had dinner uh last week or two weeks ago
casa d'angelo
and uh he said you know i just had
dinner with uh with solomon david
solomon
he said uh two months prior to that he
said he flew out on his jet not with a
team of five eight people he fled by
himself because they were trying to do a
round of 900 million whatever the number
was he says he flew out by himself and
we sat down we talked and then he left
he had a two-hour meeting with me that's
it he just left i'm like he came himself
yeah he didn't send anybody else no he
came himself yes
you got to respect the leader like that
that's
remember remember what jamie dimon said
recently he said no more zoom because
he'd lost business of course of course
this is one time solomon kind of took
everyone's lunch and you got to respect
that i'm sure you have an opinion also
for jamie
i think jamie's uh almost a class by
himself i mean he's terrific guy i have
a very high regard for that but i know
well
um
and i think goldman i mean goldman is a
very accomplished firm very motivated
wants to do the business
i had my own experience you know i was
one of the few times i was ahead of
goldman
in terms of thinking
i ran goldman research for many many
years and
i kept on telling goldman you're making
mistake by not being in the asset
management business and for 10 years
they told me lee you don't get it we
believe go money manage to do money
management bus you know brokers firms to
do brokerage don't compete with your
customer because goldman's traditional
customers a professional money manager
i said open up your eyes and look around
the world has changed you know merrill
lynch asset management uh webster which
is division of key key to peabody csfb
everybody was in the business
and they didn't want to do it then one
day uh solomon brothers who was an arts
trading rival in the 70s and 60s
announced that bob solomon jr was
leaving the research department to start
solomon brothers asset management and
steve friedman bob rubin called me up
they were there the co-heads of the firm
said you know you were right we were
wrong we made a mistake we should go
into asset management
are you willing to leave research and
start an asset management division for
us
and i left i said sure
it was a mistake on my part because
goldman being the great firm it is
understood that assets under management
times fee equal revenue
and i was interested in the performance
of the assets not raising assets
and uh
after about a year of doing it i decided
i want to retire and become a full-time
money manager
uh but you know goldman when they go
into a business some they're not the
first but when they go into a business
they try to capture 100 market shares
they're very motivated gsam is a monster
yeah it is yeah and i started it's a
trillion dollar business now is is it
it sat down with a a small private
equity firm out of new york they came
into my house last week nice people good
guys
and their team five people there goldman
sachs former goldman sachs 28 years
former goldman sachs 26 years former
goldman sachs 25 years former goldman
sachs 26 years
i see it a lot after 25 years is there
like something that happens at 25 years
at goldman that people leave after 25
years
because because it's a great firm but i
see a lot at 25 26 different now than it
used to be because people would spend
their whole careers there and then
either only leap to go into government
or academia sure uh you know
i don't know exactly what's changed but
i would say that uh
you know when you get up in the morning
you have one suit
you look in the closet you don't have to
spend a lot of time thinking about what
you're going to wear
okay goldman you know partners at age 50
are worth a lot of money and you have
more than one suit in the closet and
it's a very demanding business very hard
work i had a voracious appetite for work
so i didn't leave over that i just
wanted to do something different i did
not want to run another business now
in research
self-praised things but we had a very
good team of sales research and training
coordinating together when i took over
goldman research we were largely
unranked in these various surveys that
checked institutional investor
magazine greenwich research which was
founded by charlie ellis financial world
which isn't in business anymore i took
over the research department we were
unranked in those polls when i left the
research department we were number one
in every one of those surveys and there
was a category called portfolio strategy
which i competed in as a as a soloist
and uh for nine straight years i was
voted number one strategist so i was
ready for new mountain to climb and
that's when i went into asset management
but like i said i wanted to be a money
manager and uh
not an asset gatherer so i i selfishly
have to ask
how how did the federal reserve's
policies as they evolved
changed how you
how you
looked at managing money
well i would say the business has
changed not so much with the federal
reserve as business changed
because the machines now run the world
and i'm highly critical of the sec
um you know i wrote jay clayton a letter
which he never responded to he's now in
private practice ironically he's
chairman of the board of apollo which i
have a large position when i wrote him a
letter when he was ahead of the sec he
never responded i pointed out to him
when i came to goldman sachs 50 odd
years ago
goldman morgan stanley solomon traded
stocks for 25 50 cents a share and the
volca rule didn't exist so the brokers
had the capacity and the willingness to
position and create liquidity they can't
anymore legally because of volcker and
economically because of the commission
structure there's no reward
secondly
50 years ago the specialist system
handled the new york stock chain handled
80 of the volume today 80 percent of the
volume is off board and dark pools and
finally one particularly critical in i
think 2007
they eliminated the uptick rule
which was enacted in 1938 in response to
the abuses of 29.
and this gave rise to all the machines
to trade the way they trade and these
machines know nothing about value they
know everything about price and so the
market goes up too much when it goes up
it goes down too much when it goes down
and it's a destabilizing force but
they don't seem to be focused on that
they seem to be focused more on the
trading costs
i don't know i just operate in the world
that i'm in i'm happy i'm not in the
money management game professionally
where i'm being paid a fee
i can take a long-term horizon
and uh
run the money for tax efficiency leon
for for the average person that's having
a hard time with gas i saw this article
the other i don't know if you saw this
or not is inflation ruining your day
just eat lentils and let your pets die
corporations artificially inflating
prices bloomberg bloomberg opinion came
out the other day saying inflation
stinks most if you earn less than 300
000 a year here's how to deal with it
take the bus
don't buy in bulk
try lentils instead of meat nobody said
this would be fun okay
what are your thoughts about some of
these things on how people are handling
uh the rise of gas prices
well
if they're economically sensitive
they're going to drive less right and
take public transportation
and the politicians are trying to ease
the pain so they're reducing gasoline
taxes when they should be
not doing that
yeah there's there's talk about price
controls which is really scary that
didn't work for nixon no no no i hope we
don't go in that direction i mean these
oil companies are coining money no
question about it
i'm doing relatively well in the markets
have 20 of my portfolio in energy and i
just tell you look at the numbers
they're powerful powerful well they're
not they're not making stupid
investments anymore well they're afraid
to because they've convinced the public
the administration has but esg
and then it's a sunset industry and they
you know so they're afraid to make
investments so they're returning the
money in the form of dividends and stock
repurchases can't blame them
no but uh you know i believe that this
uh capitalist system adjusts and things
will happen do you think you think this
is we're seeing the the high with gas
prices and inflation or it's
still going to continue the rest of the
year i think it's going to continue
until the fed gets out ahead of things
or the price of energy pushes us into
recession i think we're heading to a
recession i don't think in 2022 but i
think in 2023 is a growing probability
of recession and that will bring the
market down
by how much what are you thinking well
i'm thinking uh
if when a recession hits the market have
dropped 40 percent from its high
so the high was 4 800 so that'd be near
3 000
but not this year
that's a pretty that's a big number
right there yeah well it's a big number
but uh we're
see the discussion is just centered
around what is the appropriate multiple
for the market
and i when i consider the degree of
involvement by the government in the
system i say an 18 multiple in the s p
is a reasonable number well 18 times 225
230 dollars says the market's fairly
valued at 4 000. the market's been kept
in overvalued territory by very very
accommodating monetary policy and that's
changing i think powell will be the
first to admit that he made a huge
mistake translation huge biggest policy
error the fed has ever made
okay i absolutely agree
and so i i think that interest rates can
get up to the point where it'll
hit the economy it may take another year
to get there
right now the stock market is benefiting
into some degree but we're the best game
in town you know they say in the land of
the blind the one iron man is king or
the tallest [ __ ] you don't want to
invest in europe now because of
proximity to russia
trying to big questions about rule of
law and fixed income is
totally mispriced
so you know the u.s market wins by
default
as richard fisher used to say the most
attractive horse in the glue factory
okay
but that sounds reasonable so we had an
interesting comment and maybe danielle
can give some thoughts on this uh paul
volcker had it right higher rates lower
prices
that's the cure
that is the cure but as lee just said
jay powell missed the window and now
it's going to prove very costly because
he's going to have to channel hopefully
his inner paul volcker paul volcker
purposely put the u.s economy into
recession in order to get inflation
tamed
and the the economy paid a price
and you have to have somebody with us
with the spine and the constitution to
to go that distance right now because
the fed is as they say so far behind the
curve and in fact senator shelby asked
powell outright in his recent
congressional testimony
can you be volcker and powell answered
him i hope when history's written that
the answer is yes
it remains to be seen you know the fed
is only raised by a quarter of one
percentage point there are 700 basis
points seven full percentage points
behind where they should be in terms of
tightening and that's going to be that's
going to be painful in an interest rate
sensitive economy it is very clear that
powell and the fiscal side of the
economy
has elevated societal issues relative to
inflation as a concern
absolutely
just remember every recession sows the
seeds in the next economic recovery and
every economic recovery sow the seeds in
the next recession he used to have
recessions every four or five years the
last recession we had was 2008 2009.
he's going to try to engineer a soft
landing but my guess is we're so far
from
reality in terms of rates that it's not
going to happen it wouldn't be a bad
thing we've got 20 of us companies are
what they call zombies they can't they
can't service their interest expense so
recessions had been cleansing when they
came around with regularity every four
or five you get the bad players out of
the market well they say a rolling loan
gathers no loss
that's very good are you following what
they're saying with you know biden's
warning about cyber attacks from russia
are you following that story yeah um how
much credibility do you give to that
that that could happen
oh i would say very credible and i'm
just hoping the government
is astute enough to
have plans i remember i joined
wall street almost 60 years ago and one
of the first companies i visited was a
company called bemis company
okay in minneapolis
and they told me they had just completed
a government contract
you breathe news to you to bury a couple
hundred million shrouds along the
eastern seaboard because they felt in
the event of a nuclear attack we
wouldn't have the time to bury everybody
so we had shrouds buried along the
eastern seaboard to cover the bodies in
the streets
so the government's always thinking for
us know hopefully they know what's best
ah they know what's best they know
what's best for you liam i see the smile
on your face of course i mean you're
talking to the guy who escaped that to
be here so i can make a decision for
myself if i screw up
go be it but no this is what biden said
he said on march 21st the more putin's
back is against the wall
the greater the severity of the tactics
he may employ
one of the tools he most likely to use
in my view in our view is cyber attacks
the magnitude of russia's cyber capacity
is fairly consequential and it's coming
he continued so
you know does anybody does anybody
really know
what that would look like is anybody
talking about what that would be they
shut down the power grids and stuff like
that yeah and that's where they can be
the most and the they did to the
colonial pipeline yeah you know
where they had gas lines for a while
look this is a different form of war and
hopefully it's cyber and not nuclear
you know
you read my mind much more dangerous
but that's a good way to to sow the
seeds of societal unrest in a in an
economy that that's plagued by
inequality is you turn the lights out we
have to decide whether we're a
capitalist nation or a socialist nation
i think one of the biggest threats this
country has is from what i read 30
percent of the young people think
socialism is referred to capitalism it's
even harder scary so scary did you see
the chart about the support for union
since 1965
did you see that chart that was shared
okay tyler do you have that or no
if you have that if you can pull that up
make it okay so this is from our uh uh
go go a little lower so he knows who
it's from that's from robert reich i'm
sure which you appreciate robert wright
yeah robert other socialist another
socialist absolutely public support for
unions is at a 50-year high this is a
big deal you see approval rating how
high it is 68 last time we were there
was 1965 a year before you got
with uh goldman
uh is this
for for the average person i was like
what's the big deal unions are good
because they protect the employee
what does this mean to the average
person that's reading this i'm not
anti-union but i would basically just
say it's very clear that the
power is shifting from capital to labor
right now
and that's one of the reasons i'd have a
conservative view about the market
you know
i'm not anti-union uh
basically i'm
this is just a fact of life did the
pendulum swing too far in terms of
well income clarity is a big issue i'm
talking about ceo pay versus the people
who are working for the companies yeah
uh it has but you know
one buffer says that uh
you know they ought to name these uh
consultants ratchet ratchet and ratchet
because they're just coming they bless
what the boards want to do
i think it is a big problem
you know i own stock in a
company
that the ceo has made a shitload of
money a huge huge amount of money and
the stock is lower than it was a decade
ago
and
this is wrong
and you know i just don't have a time to
tilt the windmills so i
keep the position small or i just move
on
and sell well at the end of the day you
get what you pay for and you can pay
people to be productive
you can but i think that
business is getting paid more than they
uh produced
and you quote like carl icahn he's a big
soapbox on that and he's not wrong
but uh business is getting paid more
than they produce
in some instances yes in some instances
they get paid less
you know uh like i said one of my heroes
was henry singleton of teledyne never
made more than a million dollars a year
uh running the company
and he was absolutely brilliant in
everything he did
you know he basically did 130
acquisitions intelligently
he uh basically bought stocks and other
companies intelligently
he uh managed his own capital structure
he brought back 90 of his stock before
dying
uh very intelligently he made the
investors a shitload of money never
never got paid a lot of money and he
made the money but he owned 20 of the
company
and he was totally aligned with the
shareholders
i think that this income disparity is a
very long-term issue and it has to be
dealt with through education
okay
amen well you know uh basically uh
you got to create economic opportunity
for people and you got to give them the
tools to be competitive
and i think education is the best way to
do it
are you familiar with michael saylor
uh he's the crypto guy he's a crypto guy
yeah i take a cop out on crypto they say
if you don't understand crypto it means
you're old i'm 78 i don't understand
crypto i don't want to say it's a fraud
i think blockchain technology is for
real i don't understand crypto i i got a
couple million bucks for the money
manager it has a four percent position
so i got eighty thousand dollars in
crypto you got eighty thousand dollars
in crypto yeah that's right so that's
two bitcoins give or take
two and a half million dollars
two bitcoin i i know nothing about it i
don't have an intelligent view
i know smart people on both sides so me
too and i'm and i'm uh uh i own a pos i
have a position in bitcoin and ethereum
but i'm i a person wouldn't call me like
oh this guy's a you know full-on but i
had michael saylor here the other day
and one guy seems like a very smart guy
well you said education i said so why
are you doing these things this is only
one reason i got to educate people i got
educated about by why bitcoin makes
sense the one part that uh
more and more i think about it more and
more i think about what's going on is
when when what took place with ukraine
and uh russia what's going on right now
over there right or what happened with
canada the whole truckers what they were
doing
they can shut down your checking account
if they wanted to they can shut down
your credit cards they can shut down
access to a lot of that stuff i can't
send gold to you my family in iran and
say hey you're going through tough times
here in 30 seconds i'm going to send you
gold i can't set that if if the
direction of how exchange can take place
the blockchain technology as well as
bitcoin or ethereum that's making more
and more sense
for the younger audience and some of the
older guys are starting to say maybe
this does make sense but charlie munger
came out and which rat poison yeah he
called the bread poisonous woody yeah he
can say whatever he wants he did not say
good things about uh
bitcoin i was more in line with him but
the truth is i've learned over the years
you speak about things you know
something about i i don't know enough
about it charlie's a very bright guy
and he speaks his mind
uh jamie dimon has said things about it
warren buffett said things about it
i don't i don't think it's in the
interest of the u.s dollar to uh the u.s
country to promote an alternative
currency
um
but it may emerge on its own who knows
do you have control over that that's
free marketing right the market i think
they've missed their chance there's
trillions of dollars now held in this
stuff so that out laura they'll just tax
it to death that's all they'll
they'll basically have adverse taxes on
uh bitcoin final thoughts i'll give you
here with the audience okay with uh
uh uh where the market is at your life
experiences if you can give advice to me
i'm listening to this i'm like listen
okay
here's a guy that's given me perspective
from a billionaire standpoint you're a
billionaire what do you know what it is
to be middle america why should i give
my life and go out there and work hard
and make some money why not socialism
why not these rich people all they care
about is money all they care about is
becoming rich all they care about is
that and then they bully the small guy
why not socialism what would you say to
the
folks that maybe are more supportive of
that social media
look at the most prosperous economy in
the world
it's not a socialism
i went to cuba and we explained we
talked about that venezuela these are
all economies in the toilet look at
russia
you know
you know
it's clear that capitalism has been the
most successful
and so uh i would say that uh
just look at the facts
you know most of the time most of the
people in these socialist countries want
to come to
america of course they do yeah and uh
i'm the american dream you know my
father came to america at 13
i got to all public school education i
worked hard made a lot of money and
giving it all away that's the american
dream america became successful not
because we envied people with wealth we
want to become wealthy yeah and i
started i started working to put blood
on the table to support my family and
then you develop a certain work style
work habit and i work very hard but i
work very hard and give away my money
and i like giving away money
i i like making money for two reasons if
i make money and don't lose money it
validates my views and all of us have a
certain degree of arrogance you want to
be right i don't want to sit in your
program give out bad advice i want to
give out advice that makes people money
okay the second reason you want to make
money is to give away more money
it makes me happy you're optimistic
about the future
i would say uh not as optimistic as i'd
like to be and okay warren buffett says
it and well that you know no way we got
rich being short america but i i don't
like the uh polarization of the country
i don't like the leadership that we have
and i think that this debt creation is
going to come back and bite us in the
ass
every
you know
every bubble that we've been through has
had a very bad economic outcome and
and i think that that is in the period
ahead of us
so
where i would close on not that the
market's going to collapse or anything
like that but i got my mba from columbia
business school on january 31st of 1967.
at a six month old kid had no money in
the bank had a student loan to repay i
was broke i couldn't afford a vacation
very next day i started my 24th credit
goldman sachs february 1st of 67. if you
go back and check the charts you'll see
in february 1st of 1967 the dow was
roughly a thousand in 1982 was roughly a
thousand
wow 15 years later 15 years later now
i'm not making a 15-year forecast but i
am of the view that we're in store for
an extended period of time and very low
returns in the equity market we may have
a big swash down next year and we come
back to where we are now but i don't
think we're going anywhere for a few
years and you're gonna have to work hard
and you know be a stock picker and
just be disciplined don't be a margin be
a cash-based investor and know what you
own
there's no miracles we've been through
one of the most speculative periods in
history i mean uh just look at you know
and i said this on tv a while ago
there's not one market you know there's
the s p market is the fang market and
then there's the uh robinhood market and
the robinhood market was crazy they had
no idea what they were doing those
stocks are down 70 80 90 percent and
they still don't own one and they still
look expensive robin and stock has gone
from like
80 to single digits down 80 odd percent
and they don't earn money so you know i
buy companies that are only companies
that earn money smartest guy in the room
there was the amc ceo who kept selling
stock into it and now he's buying again
and i don't know what he's buying but
we'll see well the first of all
appreciate you for coming out this was
great i'm glad we were able to have you
on the
podcast here danielle it's good that we
did it together and the timing was
perfect because you guys your your
backgrounds collide uh together folks
we'll do the podcast again i think next
tuesday
with honton that created the ai company
i believe his database is the largest in
the world of faces and facial
recognition it's pretty wild what he's
got a little creepy little scary but
something i want to learn more about if
that interests you we'll see you next
tuesday have a great weekend everybody
take care bye bye bye bye bye cheers
you